opération séduction tour de la ryder cup
2018 ce mardi 17 octobre lever du soleil
les deux capitaines de la compétition
jim furyk et tomates bio m'ont tapé
quelques balles du haut du premier étage
de la tour eiffel devant les caméras
quelques heures plus tard dans un hôtel
parisien les golfeurs ont lancé
officiellement les hostilités lors d'une
conférence de presse c'est le top départ
du raz du ryder cup 2018 c'est
maintenant les capitaines se rencontrent
que c'est du sérieux que ils ont une
équipe a formé dans la salle des
dizaines de journalistes venus du monde
entier la conférence a notamment été
retransmise en direct sur les grandes
chaînes de télévision américaines et
britanniques
c'est un événement énorme c'est
l'événement le plus important pour le
golf à l'échelle mondiale sans aucune
question possible c'est un événement qui
passionne les foules en grande bretagne
c'est le 3ème 4ème évènement le plus
important le plus suivi au monde
et là on a l'impression que les français
sont en train de découvrir tant mieux il
reste encore onze mois pour que la
france l'approprient sur le plan sportif
pas de grandes annonces pendant ces
trente minutes de questions-réponses
l'américain jim furyk a tout de même
annoncé compter sur la super star tiger
woods si ce dernier avait le feu vert
des médecins
du côté des européens thomass bjorn a
prévenu qu'aucun golfeur n'avait sa
place assurée dans l'équipe y compris
les français il faut pas je pense qu'il
a été clair espérer ou attendre à une
comment dire un choix wild card naturel
pour un français après jean van de velde
et thomas levet et victor dubuisson un
quatrième français sera-t-il sur les
greens du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines du 28 au 30
septembre 2018
réponse dans 11 mois